CAMPAIGN.
IT SHOULD BE -- IT IS ONE IF
NOT THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
SCANDAL IN OUR HISTORY HERE
WITH REACTION IS HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN
NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK.
>> Sean: I AM A BIT STUNNED
AT THE SCHIFF MEMO.
I GUESS THERE IS A REASON
THAT MANY IN THE LIBERAL
MEDIA AREN'T COVERING IT
BECAUSE IT CORROBORATES SO
MUCH OF WHAT YOU SAID THE
STEELE DOSSIER AS THE GRAHAM
GRASSLEY MEMO SAYS WAS THE
BULK OF THE INFORMATION, THE
PHONY UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, THAT WAS THE
BIBLICAL OF THE FISA BLUCK
OF THE
OF -HE
OF --E
OF -- BULK OF THE FIGHT.
>> IT'S THE BULK OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE USED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS WENT BACK
TO CARTER PAGE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO THAT THEY STARTED
TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM
THE DOSSIER WHICH WAS THEIR
INFORMATION THAT THEY PAID
FOR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND THEY -- WHAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO ME IS.
SO HILLARY, SHE HAS BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR, HER AND THE
DNC, THEN IT'S USED AS THE
BASIS FOR A FISA WARRANT.
BUT HERE IS WHAT IS NOT
ADDRESSED BY ADAM SCHIFF AND
HE LOVES TELEVISION.
I MEAN, IS HE LITERALLY
AUDITIONING DAILY TO BE AN
MSNBC CONTRIBUTOR.
BUT THE MOST GLARING THING
TO ME IS THAT IT NEVER
MENTIONS IN HIS MEMO AT ALL
CLINTON OR THE DNC, JUST
LIKE IT LIKE IT WAS NEVER
TOLD TO THE FISA JUDGE.
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM
FROM THE BEGINNING, REMEMBER
THAT WAS ONLY ABOUT FISA
ABUSE.
PHASE ONE WAS TO SAY LOOK
FISA ABUSE OCCURRED.
THE REASON WE WANTED THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO OUT IF YOU
RECALL OVER TWO WEEKS AGO AS
SOON AS THAT AS SOON AS IT
WAS SENT OVER TO THE WHITE
HOUSE HEY WE WANT IT OUT.
THE WHITE HOUSE CAME BACK.
THE FBI AND DON SAID HEY,
MAKE THE CHANGES AND GET IT
BACK OUT.
THEN WHAWP HAD IS THIS
SUPPOSED COVERUP.
THEY WERE BLAMING THE
PRESIDENT.
SAYING THE PRESIDENT WEAPGHT
GETTING THIS OUT.
THAT WAS THE FARTHEST THING
FROM THE TRUTH.
THEY COULD HAVE GOTTEN THIS
OUT TWO WEEKS AGO.
THEY COULD HAVE MADE THE
REDACTIONS THE FBI AND DOJ
WANTED AND THEY COULD HAVE
GOTTEN THIS OUT.
WE WANTED IT OUT FOR
PRECISELY THE REASONS THAT
YOU ARE MENTIONING TONIGHT.
>> THE DOJ AND FBI NEVER
VERIFIED THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
ALTHOUGH THEY KNEW IT WAS
POLITICAL IN NATURE, THAT
SHE HAD PAID FOR IT?
THEY NEVER DID THEIR OWN
VERIFICATION?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S WHAT
IS EVEN MORE TELLING ABOUT
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO THAT WE
LIKE IS THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY SAYING -- THEY
ACTUALLY SAY IN THERE IN THE
FOOTNOTE AND THEY GIVE YOU
THE VERBATIM.
THEY GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
ACTUALLY SAY HOW THIS WAS
USED, HOW IT WAS POLITICAL.
BUT THEN THEY DON'T SAY
SPECIFICALLY WHO PAID FOR IT
APPEARED WE JUST CAN'T HAVE
A FISA COURT, WE CAN'T HAVE
OUR INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
USED TO TARGET ONE POLITICAL
PARTY AGAINST ANOTHER.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> Sean: ISN'T THAT LYING BY
OMISSION, SIR?
>> WELL, I'M NOT AN EXPERT
ON THAT, SEAN, BUT CLEARLY
THE WAY WE SEE IT, IT WAS A
LOT MORE COMPLICATED TO PUT
WHAT THEY PUT IN TO WHAT
THE -- TO PUT WHAT THE FBI
AND DOJ PRESENTED TO THE
FISA COURT THAN IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN JUST TO SAY LOOK,
HERE, JUDGE, THIS IS WHO
PAID FOR IT.
>> Sean: I GUESS THE NEXT
THING I WANT TO KNOW IS SO
WE HAVE HAD ALLEGATION AFTER
ALLEGATION AFTER ALLEGATION
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE TO
DATE OF ANY TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION OF ANY KIND THAT
YOU OR ANYBODY ON YOUR
COMMITTEE OR ANYBODY IN THE
FBI OR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OR ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION HAS COME UP
WITH THAT YOU HAVE SEEN?
>> NOT THAT I HAVE SEEN.
AND THE ONLY COLLUSION THAT
I CONTINUE TO SAY THAT I
HAVE SEEN AND WE HAVE PROOF
OF IS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HIRED A BRITISH AGENT,
FORMER BRITISH AGENT WHO
WENT TO SUPPOSED RUSSIANS TO
GET DIRT ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
I MEAN THAT IS -- IT IS
COLLUSION, IT IS CLEAR
COLLUSION AND NOBODY IS
INVESTIGATING IT AND NOBODY
IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: ARE CRIMES IN YOUR
VIEW COMMITTED HERE IN TERMS
OF THE FISA APPLICATION, THE
ROLE OF HIGH RANKING NOT
RANK AND FILE, HIGH RANKING
FBI, DOJ INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE
AND WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT
THIS WHOLE YEAR PLUS THAT
THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
CONSUMED WITH AN
INVESTIGATION THAT
APPARENTLY HAS NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER SHOULD IT GO
AWAY?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK YOU
HAVE -- THERE IS A VARIETY
OF CRIMES THAT YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT.
HAVE YOU CONSPIRACY WOULD BE
THE LARGEST, ALSO THE
HARDEST TO PROVE.
YOU HAVE A LYING MISLEADING
CONGRESS.
YOU HAVE THE COURT THAT
COULD ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
IF THEY FEEL LIKE THEY WERE
LIED TO.
BUT THE BIGGER PROBLEM HERE,
I THINK, OVERALL OF THIS.
JUST FOR -- FISA ABUSE
SPECIFICALLY, IS I JUST
THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
REJECT THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN
USE A SECRET COURT, TAKE
POLITICAL DIRT FROM ONE
PARTY AND USE IT AGAINST
ANOTHER.
I THINK ALL AMERICANS WITH
CAN AGREE WITH THAT.
>> Sean: DIDN'T GLENN
SIMPSON ALSO ADMIT IN
TESTIMONY THAT IN FACT HE
NEVER CORROBORATED, HE NEVER
VERIFIED, AND AT TIMES I
BELIEVE IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
THE SENATE.
MAYBE NOT YOUR COMMITTEE.
BUT I BELIEVE HE ALSO
ADMITTED THAT THEY HAD
COORDINATED, IN TERMS OF
MEDIA OUTREACH TO GET OUT
INFORMATION THAT WAS NEVER
VERIFIED THAT WAS CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR.
THAT WAS CONNECTED TO
RUSSIA?
>> WELL, LOOK, YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME, I MEAN, YOU KNOW
THAT GLENN SIMPSON AND
STEELE WERE MEETING WITH
NUMEROUS REPORTERS.
MAYBE THIS IS WHY WHEN I SAY
THE MEDIA IS DEAD.
MAYBE THEY ARE EMBARRASSED,
RIGHT?
SO MANY OF THEM WERE
BRIEFED, MAYBE THEY CAN'T
ACTUALLY BRIGHT ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE EMPEROR WOULD
HAVE NO CLOTHES.
HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY IF SOME
OF THESE REPORTERS WOULD
COME OUT AND SAY YEAH, WE
WERE BRIEFED ON THIS DOSSIER
WAY BACK WHEN AND NOW
KNOWING THAT IT'S TOTALLY
FALSE AND TOTALLY DISPROVEN.
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
LAST QUESTION.
YOU SAID THIS IS PHASE ONE.
AT A ANOTHER POINT IN AN
INTRODUCE WE DID TOGETHER
YOU TALKED ABOUT AT LEAST
FOUR OTHER PHASES.
CAN YOU OUTLINE WHAT ELSE IS
COMING AND THE SPECIFIC
AREAS OF INTEREST THAT YOU
HAVE IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATIONS?
>> WELL, THE AREA THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON RIGHT NOW IS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE
QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WE HAVE
SEEN OUT SO, WE HAVE A
QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WENT OUT
TO CURRENT AND FORMER SENIOR
MEMBERS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE ASKING THEM VERY
SIMPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DOSSIER WHEN THEY KNEW ABOUT
IT, WHO THEY TOLD, WHAT THEY
KNEW THE DEMOCRATS HAD PAID
FOR IT THAT QUESTIONNAIRE IS
DUE THIS FRIDAY.
>> Sean: DID YOU FIND SUSAN
RICE'S NOTE TO SELF ON THE
FINAL DAY OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ODD?
>> WELL, I WOULD SAY IT IS A
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A LONG
STRING OF ACTIONS BY SUSAN
RICE THAT I THINK ARE ODD.
>> Sean: DOES IT SCARE YOU
THAT AN UNVERIFIED POLITICAL
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOCUMENT
FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES WITH
ALL THE TALK ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION COULD MAKE ITS WAY
TO THE FISA COURT, THAT THE
FISA JUDGE IS NOT INFORMED
ABOUT ITS ORIGINS AND THAT
IT BECOMES THE BASIS TO SPY
ON OPPOSITION PARTY IN THE
DOES THAT SCARE YOU AS MUCH
AS IT DOES ME.
>> WELL, SEAN, LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT SCARES ME MORE THAN
THAT.
IT'S THAT THE PARTY WHO DID
THAT, OKAY, MEANING THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE, WHOSE PARTY DID
THIS, THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
IN -- AND IF YOU READ THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO CLOSELY,
THEY ACTUALLY SAY THAT
THAT'S OKAY.
>> Sean: THAT'S SCARY.
>> THAT TO ME IS REALLY BAD.
IT'S NOT OVERSIGHT.
AND I THINK IT BRINGS UP
MANY QUESTIONS ABOUT WHEN
DID THEY ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT
THIS DOSSIER.
WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THEIR OWN
DOSSIER THAT THEY USED TO
DRUM UP AN INVESTIGATION ON
REPUBLICANS.